we're playing two truths and a lie with
best friends Brooke Shields and Ali
Wentworth oh and surprising them with
their other best friend that's what
we're about to do right now watch
watch one of your besties needs to be
invited into this thrupple
um uh she just take destroy the video
we are shooting SVU just shooting with
iced tea no big deal it's time to play
two groups and a lot so I'm going to
give you three facts about each of us
and you have to figure out which one is
a lot Drew has a chicken named Blanche
she keeps the original
ET in her daughter's room the thoughts
of goat cheese makes her Ralph
oh wow I'm gonna go with the original
ET not not being in your closet and you
are 100 correct
that is the LIE
I do and not I have uh E.T in my room
Mariska what's next
what is the lie about
when Brooke is stressed she makes
origami she spent one Thanksgiving in an
igloo
for high heels once caused her to crash
into
her
well I know the LIE is you don't do
origami when you're stressed right
funny thing is that the other two are so
ridiculous my heels got caught on my on
the gas pedal and I drove into my
kitchen and I took out the pillar of the
house but that that's the story you're
going with that's true oh I didn't know
that it stuck and I was on the phone and
and yeah and I I we did do construction
do you have your license just out of
curiosity yes I do yeah okay
it's your turn roll the clip sorry
the next one is about Alec Drew and
Brooke which one is alive Allie didn't
shave before blind date with George she
once tap danced for Henry Kissinger she
won the joke roping competition in
eighth grade what was the last one she
won a jump roping competition in eighth
grade
I mean I'm gonna guess tap dancing for
Kissinger
do you have a guess
so odd that I'm what was the first one
um I didn't shave or shower my first
date with drinks
who is her happy husband how dare you
okay that's true yes okay
um I'm I'm
I don't know about the jump roping I
could see you in the White House doing a
little dance for Kissinger I did I dance
by Henry Kissinger for Nixon's 60th
birthday but I don't see you jump right
nope I don't I will not shimmy my tush
for nothing
well I'm so glad I got it right
otherwise I'd be held to pay yeah later
all right and I can fail and be blind
and Mariska Hargitay we'll be right back
[Music]